the same haircut that got me called
pisshead was what started my actual
career we live in a crazy world and
we're living in an insane time please be
kind to yourselves and stand up for
yourself please
from heartfelt words of encouragement
from the Jonas Brothers and Taylor Swift
to a few things that left us sort of
scratching our heads et is taking a look
at the best worst and weirdest moments
from the 2019 Teen Choice Awards
[Applause]
sarah hyland dazzled throughout the
evening not only did she totally Rock
her new rock from fiancee Wells Adams
she also slayed her first performance of
her new single with Jordan McGraw
called met at a party and another best
moment for sure Noah sent nao sharing an
inspiring message about anti bullying I
just love you guys and and you can't let
anyone tell you you can't do something
much more inspiring words from Taylor
Swift who received the first-ever Teen
Choice icon award the only thing cooler
than seeing her three cats on the
surfboard was listening to her speech
but if you're out there and you're being
really hard on yourself right now for
something that's happened or messing up
or feeling embarrassed it's normal
another uplifting moment the Joe Broz
were given the Teen Choice decade award
they reminded us that it's cool to be
different those things that you feel
like you're singled out about you're
bullied about that define you and your
teen years can become the thing that
makes you special as your gift it's your
power but we do have one small bone to
pick we wanted more fans were a little
confused by the show's open which
featured several dancers rocking out on
the beach - the Jonas Brothers hit
sucker we were hoping that meant we'd
eventually get to see them sing but no
such luck and of course it wouldn't be a
proper award show without some moments
that were unique to say the least
like this one where the audience tried
to set the record for most selfies taken
at the Teen Choice Awards
and how about this a bunch of sharks
dancing on stage - what else baby shark
and last but not least unexpected yet
hilarious can John called out a certain
youtuber Jay Paul over here would be
pissed and that could stress out his
pretend marriage lead to a fake divorce
from his not wife
[Music]